In this walkthrough we build a cohort in PIC-SURE from start to finish.
First we search for a concept, blood pressure, and look at the variables each study offers for it.
Each result shows the study, the variable name and how many participants have a value for it.
We add systolic blood pressure as a filter and drag the range slider to keep values above one forty.
The participant count at the top updates straight away, so we can see the effect of every filter.
Next we add a categorical filter for smoking status and tick the current and former smoker values.
Filters combine with AND by default, so the cohort shrinks with each filter we add to it.
To combine filters with OR instead, we drag one filter onto another and they become a group.
Groups can be nested two levels deep, which covers most of the cohort definitions we see in practice.
Now the cohort looks right, so we save it before doing anything else with it.
Unsaved filters are cleared when you sign out, which is the most common way people lose a cohort.
With the cohort saved, we open the export tab and pick the variables to include in the dataset.
We choose the workspace to export into; it needs a billing project, or the export will fail.
Large exports run in the background, and an email arrives when the dataset is ready, usually within ten minutes.
The exported dataset is named after the date and the cohort, so it is easy to find in the workspace.
Remember that authorized access exports only include the studies you are approved for.
That is why the participant count can drop between the open access view and the exported dataset.
To change the cohort later, reopen it from the saved cohorts list, edit the filters and export again.
That is the whole cycle: search, filter, save, export, and analyze the dataset in your workspace.